conspiracy and on your screen is
Professor Michael Barkin he's in
Syracuse and I want to start by first
saying good morning but asking professor
Barkin what his favorite conspiracy is
well the favorite conspiracy that I
would have as a scholar of conspiracies
is simply the one that tries to explain
the most what's the the cover of your
book has the big eye on it what's that
mean well that of course is the reverse
side of the Great Seal of the United
States and the image has taken off of
the back of the one dollar bill if you
look at a lot of the conspiracy theories
that are out there they tend to regard
that so-called all-seeing eye at the top
of the pyramid as a symbol of the
Illuminati the secret society who
allegedly are masterminding the New
World Order takeover well let me start
by asking you also what a conspiracy is
I would regard a conspiracy belief as
the belief that there is some
organization operating covertly
to reach evil malevolent ends overnight
I was telling the audience earlier I was
listening to this radio program that has
millions of listeners overnight called
coast-to-coast am George Noory
is the host it used to be hosted by art
Bell and they talked about UFOs they
overnight they had a gentleman on the
name of Alex Jones who has a talk show
in Texas I think and it's heard in
communities around the United States and
he was talking about the Bohemian Grove
Club as if that's where it all happens
that's where all the decisions are made
there are thousands of people go there
and there's some kind of a ceremony
surrounding an owl and all that if you
followed this at all
yes I have even though the show is on
past my bedtime but Alex Jones has been
talking about this for for quite a while
the Bohemian Grove of course is a
privately owned redwood grove
in Sonoma County north of San Francisco
where every summer there is get-together
of the wealthy and and well-placed all
all-male who get together for general
cavorting socializing lectures symposia
and so on and an atmosphere that is
completely removed from public scrutiny
Alex Jones and some others have
suggested for a long time that there are
all sorts of nefarious rituals that go
on and as a matter of fact a couple of
years ago and I talked about this
incident actually in in in my book
someone who had listened to the Alex
Jones Show about this was arrested
within the Bohemian Grove very heavily
armed because he said he was trying to
bring attention to what he thought were
human sacrifices that were being
committed by the elite who attend these
gatherings what about the skull and
bones
skull and bones obviously gets a good
deal of attention simply because a it's
it's secret and B the members are are
people who often turn up in high places
later in life and will certainly hear
lots about it this year because both
George W Bush and John Kerry were
members most of the conspiracy theories
that are that are out there now tend to
place a lot of emphasis on the notion
that there are interlocking secret
organizations that hold the real power
in the world and because of its secrecy
and because of the
Elite background of many of its members
skull and bones is a prime candidate for
that now I see that you have graduated
from Northwestern and you got a master's
in PhD from that University in political
science and that you've taught at
Syracuse since 1965 and you're a native
of Chicago is that all right that's all
correct and before we take our first
call what got you interested in
conspiracies in the first place what got
me interested is that I had been
involved in a research project back in
the late 80s and early 1990s on extreme
right-wing groups in in America and
obviously a lot of those tended to place
a lot of great emphasis on conspiracy
theories but then as I looked further I
began to see many of the same ideas
diffusing out to the broader culture and
in fact making appearances and venues
that one wouldn't expect them obviously
mainstream films and television programs
like the x-files basically recycle a lot
of material that in the past one would
have found only in fringe subcultures
well by the way what do you think of
radio shows that do spend every night
talking about UFOs and black helicopters
and folks landing out in area 51 and all
that from other planets and photographs
that they have of flying saucers and all
that is that a good idea about idea well
obviously given a society in which we we
prize freedom of speech people can use
radio shows for for whatever they wish
there's no reason why I would make some
kind of a judgement about that Lake
Zurich Illinois you're on with Michael
Barkin and go ahead please morning
thanks for taking my call
I tried to call William Bennett about
the issue of skull and bones earlier
this week and I talked with your
screener and I told him what I wanted to
ask
Bennett about and he cut me off so if
the viewers think that we're getting
unbiased c-span information here that
may put that into question a little bit
okay then why are we letting you talk
about it this morning because I didn't
really bring up going bones this time
when I asked you might that's our topic
this morning so maybe that's the reason
why you didn't get on the other time
okay but the other day there was no
topic it was an open topic but he's go
ahead let's go right ahead what's your
question then okay I'm reading the new
American magazine and that's the John
Birch magazine correct and it has an
article about the bipartisan bipartisan
Bonesmen
and it's really their point that secret
societies are always inimical to free
societies and it's impossible to judge
whether elected officials are acting as
public service or have hidden agendas so
I'd like you to cover that issue please
thank you well there's a long history of
suspicion about secret societies in
America going all the way back to the
early days of the Republic when the
targets were frequently the Masons I
think one of the things that we have to
bear in mind here is the relationship
between secrecy and privacy in a sense a
term like secrecy has a pejorative
connotation it suggests that there's
some kind of illicit activity that needs
to be hidden and that's inimical to
democratic government on the other hand
we also prize privacy we prize freedom
of association and in in many respects
certain forms of secrecy and privacy are
two sides of the same coin if we don't
like the way in which something goes on
we say it's an example of secrecy if we
wish to protect it we call it an
instance of necessary privacy Columbus
Ohio you're on with michael barkun go
ahead Lee
yeah we're talking about this conspiracy
theory and when you see what happened
when you saw what happened to the stock
market you have a ten million dollar
stock market bubble and you start
looking at let's say you look at a
common world comp and right now the big
deal is well how did they hide ten
billion dollars in front well the
question isn't on how they hide hit them
billion dollars in fraud the question is
how did worldcom become a company worth
350 billion dollars for that to happen
you have to have the FCC yes you have
the SCC you have to have the Audit
Committee you have to have the Banking
Committee you have to have all these
committees run by all these senators all
these governors all these government
agencies have to be in concert' to allow
this to happen you wouldn't see this
conspiracy theory is is you know Skull
and Bones not right now but there has to
be something involved and it also let me
ask you this do you think everybody gets
together somewhere and makes the
decision oh it evolves it evolves it's
in fact what it evolved when you see the
campaign finance came a lobbying go sky
rack and goes through the roof
well that's that that puts that that
power structure into the group of hands
are very few alright professor Barton
what are you hearing you want to comment
on I think that we need to make a
distinction between conspiracies on the
one hand and other forms of of joint
action on the other collusion
cooperation overlapping interests and so
on I'd like to reserve a term like
conspiracy for activities that are both
highly organized and intentional and do
you have an example of one that's highly
organized and intentional that's been
successful actually it's the successful
ones that I haven't looked at in the
book because my focus has been on those
conspiracy
theories that posit the notion that
there is an organization seeking world
control obviously there have been
genuine conspiracy some of them
successful some of them unsuccessful but
the more sweeping the claims are for
what a conspiracy purports to do the
more difficult it becomes to either
prove it or disprove it and in my view
the more skeptical one has to be of the
claims Palo Alto California a good
morning alright professor Barkin
mentioned that the all-seeing eye is
supposedly a symbol of the Illuminati I
was wondering what mainstream historians
think the origin of the all-seeing eye
is well as a matter of fact if you go to
the government website on the on the
Great Seal which if memory serves maybe
I can't remember whether it's on the
Department of Treasury site or some
other cabinet department but in any case
there's a quite elaborate history of the
manner in which the seal evolved and the
the symbolism I I think what has
happened in contemporary conspiracy
theories is that a kind of alternative
history has been constructed that ties
it to nefarious conspiratorial
organizations define Illuminati the
Illuminati were a small quasi Masonic
group founded in Central Europe in 1776
by a law professor named Adam Weiss how
it grew to perhaps membership in the low
four figures largely in german-speaking
parts of Central Europe it was
associated with a an opposition to minar
kacal absolutism and because of that it
began to attract the hostility of the
governments in the countries where it
was operating so by around the late
1780s it had effectively been suppressed
and put out of business what has
happened since then and particularly
since the 1790s is that a body of
literature has grown up claiming that
the Illuminati in fact were not
disbanded that they had a continued
existence that they exist today and that
they have essentially been responsible
for much of the disruption in in world
history where do they hang out so to
speak well if you look at the
contemporary conspiracy theories they
tend to be linked to a range of of other
organizations the ones that come up with
some frequency are the Trilateral
Commission the Council on Foreign
Relations the UN the Federal Reserve
there's the sense of not a single
conspiracy but of conspiracies in a way
nested within one another like Russian
dolls
and there's that Bilderberger group I
fit in that too they certainly do in
fact in the more complex and baroque
conspiracy theories there may be
literally dozens of organizations that
are regarded as components with the
Illuminati at or near the summit of some
kind of conspiratorial hierarchy
professor michael barkun at Syracuse
University this morning we go to
Williamsville New York you're on the air
oh good morning gentlemen
I'm fascinated by the subject because I
have a brother who has a mental disorder
and he's a big conspiratorial theorist
II he goes as far as I think that George
Bush planned the 9/11 attacks but I
wanted to ask the professor is you have
a conspiracy but then you have to have
the people who actually believe in it
I find that the irrational people those
who are paranoid lazy they manifest
their problems in the fact that someone
else it's someone else
is it is someone else's fault that they
are failing
I don't think a sane rational person who
is in control of his own devices is a
conspiracy theorist but that being said
by an if Yuri roll the tape and I
noticed this and you know this is not
gonna be popular with your viewers or
anything I do find that blacks when they
call your thing on the liberal lie are
all the ones are talking about well
George Bush and they said well you know
Brian you asked them specifically well
what do you mean George Bush knew about
9/11 well you know there's it just is
very and then I think it's just
unintelligent not that all of but the
ones that go on to do this are just it
is just infuriating to someone like me
you know who you know takes
responsibility for his actions and you
know it's always someone else's fault
including just talk about the people who
believe it not the conspiracy themselves
because but most of them are just
chilling thanks professor Berger let me
just add to that so it doesn't it's not
strictly a racial thing I hear all the
time when I listen in and out of these
programs people who sound very rational
very smart and intelligent come up with
these very intricate theories of the
thing from the UFO to the things we're
talking about add that into the mix and
give us says your your views on this
yeah I I'm very reluctant to equate
belief in conspiracy theories with some
form of psychopathology I don't think
there's a clear relationship one way or
the other I do think that conspiracy
theories perform certain kinds of
functions as far as the individual
psyche is concerned namely they provide
a sense of order in the world they
provide a sense that there's a kind of
plan or design because one of the key
attributes of conspiracy theories is the
belief that nothing happens by accident
and even if actions are attributed to an
evil cabal the notion that there is some
kind of moral order if you will in the
world I think is reassuring particularly
in periods of change and uncertainty
Damascus Maryland Iran
yes about conspiracy theories I think
it's basically used as a political tool
i watch c-span I research the internet a
lot and write recently acquired Dish TV
and have free speech TV so I I think I
pretty well know what's going on on that
saying I know everything what's free
speech TV it's uh it's a channel on DISH
Network and it shows programs like
Democracy Now and Project Censored it's
about the 25 most unpublicized by the
major media stories by journalists that
haven't been put out on a major media
and what I've noticed is I like
crossfire i watch them do major media i
guess because i like to be and whenever
paul begala brings up something that
i've researched
he never brings up the full truth but
he'll bring up a part of it and tucker
cars tucker carlson will immediately
pronounce conspiracy theory and
conspiracy theory you know and try to
drown out Paul what Paul's trying to say
and I think basically it's being used in
our political system as a a political
weapon against you know whoever's
pronouncing the the conspiracy theory go
thanks professor Barkin what do you
think well
I think to a considerable extent your
callers correct when a term like
conspiracy theory becomes simply a label
for denigrating a point of view that
someone disagrees with it really loses
all meaning and and all usefulness it
simply becomes a part of a polemical
rhetoric the other point that the caller
mentioned that I think is worth noting
has to do with the impact of technology
on all of this I wasn't familiar with
the TV channel that he mentioned but
it's it's really of a piece with a great
many other technological innovations
such as the internet that bring a very
much wider range of ideas and beliefs to
public visibility than we're there
before professor michael barkun at
Syracuse University Tampa Florida is
your next call go ahead please yes sir
dr. Barkin I wanted to ask you if you
heard anything about the UN and any
conspiracy as far as a new world order I
know there's a lot of Americans that's
have changed their mind about the UN and
as far as our involvement in the UN well
virtually all conspiracy theories that
talk about a new so-called new world
order give primacy to the to the UN that
that's been a motif that's been there
for for a long time it's hard for me as
a matter of fact to think of a of a
contemporary conspiracy theory that uses
the term new world order that doesn't
talk about the UN as having some kind of
a central role what about something like
OPEC OPEC has passed from view perhaps
temporarily I think in a sense there are
fashions and conspiracy theories and of
course in the nine
eighteen seventies when OPEC had very
much greater control over the flow and
and price of oil it it rose to something
close to the forefront of conspiracy
theories but in recent years it's it's
moved to the back you think when that
gas keeps going up over two bucks that
we'll start hearing that again well here
it's gotten over two bucks already but
yes I I think that's that's quite likely
there are fashions in conspiracy
theories and a lot of conspiracy
theorists as a matter of fact turn out
to be extraordinarily adaptable in the
sense that they can modify the theories
in light of whatever the circumstances
of the moment happened to be in a moment
I'll ask you about what Alex Jones says
is the impending staged capture of bin
Laden we go to Atlantic City New Jersey
you're on the air yes good morning I
listen to Alan Jones so religiously from
2:00 in the morning to 5:00 in the
morning on reel one radio on the
Internet
if anybody really wants information that
he is the man who has it believe me I
wanted to ask mr. Barkin about how the
passports of the of the hijackers were
found gift that
nine-one-one building burned up how nine
of the 19 are still alive in other
countries and how those buildings appear
to have been blown up before a professor
before you answer let me just ask our
car why is it that you believe what Alex
Jones tells you because he he makes a
lot of sense there are just too many
coincidences about the home situation
from George Bush's cool haha and I mean
totally totally and I watch a lot of
history i watch a lot of PBS I do not
watch propaganda as Hitler said it is
easier to believe a big lied and all it
was but let me go I'm going to press it
a little bit more though
now who is Alex Jones why does he have
the truth and why is everything and he
says reliable who do you know anything
about him you know he's born
you know how much education he's got uh
it just makes sense
believe me it just makes sense it just
makes sense because the other way just
doesn't doesn't make sense and I know
there's evil behind them behind the
skullenbones well let me ask you this he
says there's an impending stage capture
of bin Laden do you believe that yeah
everything's staged everything that the
skullenbones do is staged professor well
I I guess I I would ask first what the
basis is for the various assertions
about 9/11 because they really run so
clearly counter to everything else
that's been reported and but beyond that
I guess my own view would be that that
there is a role played in events by
accident by coincidence by human
stupidity by goof-ups on the part of
authorities at one point or another one
of the things that makes me skeptical
about some conspiracy theories is the
degree to which they basically deny that
there's any role played by by by
accident or incompetence in in in human
events and that seems to me to run
counter to everything we know about
history and
and and and politics the fact is that
it's hard to stage events it's
particularly hard to stage events of of
great magnitude that take place in a in
an in a clearly public venue and
therefore I think one has to ask hard
questions about those kinds of
allegations Long Island good morning I
think there's a big conspiracy in the
Middle East against us and if there's
any terrorist attacks the bill should be
on their on their back while the OPEC
all the big shots in the Middle East all
the security that's costing us around
the world without a light it should be
on their back who's conspiring in the
Middle East I think all the countries
are Saudi Arabia Egypt all the Middle
East countries we call that you call
that professor a conspiracy and is it
true I would be I would be reluctant to
call it a conspiracy only for this
reason and and that is that the history
of Middle Eastern politics suggests that
the interests of the countries that your
caller mentioned are sometimes the same
but sometimes in conflict it's certainly
possible that groups of countries tend
at a particular time to support a given
policy because their interests coincide
I don't call that a conspiracy but
there's also a great deal of evidence of
of rivalry and jealousy among these
states that suggests that any
cooperative arrangement they might have
would be exceedingly fragile recently
the press secretary the President Bush's
father wrote a book in which and I've
not read it so I've got to be careful
what I say allegedly accused
LBJ of having JFK murdered and now it's
all very strong language the press
secretary I believe is either not said
anything about it or left the impression
that he doesn't he's not in on this or I
don't know his his brother has also been
nominated to head up the Medicare
operation did you read about that and
that's I know you refer to the Kennedy
conspiracies in the book and what does
that do to a story what does that do to
the people that believe all the
conspiracies about JFK well I know I
know of the book only through the news
accounts I haven't read I haven't read
it either but of course because there
has been such an immense literature
about possible conspiracies connected to
the JFK assassination there there is in
a way a kind of a ready-made audience
for for any sort of new take on this
particularly one that on the surface at
least is as dramatic as as as this one I
I think that what one always has to ask
in a situation like this is well if this
happened or if it happened this way how
was it possible for it to remain secret
for so long a time Clinton Maryland
you're on the air hey how you doing nice
to hear from you what's up doc hopefully
got enough time for this and I'm trying
to make this as quick as possible
personally I feel you know I agree with
a lot of stuff you're saying about how
you know there's a lot of Education that
needs to go out a lot of people need to
do some further research I can hear when
people talk about you know the
conspiracy theories arise out of
people's fears and personally I feel the
biggest conspiracy theory out there has
been the conspiracy of religion and
hopefully I have enough time I'll try
and get this out as quick as possible
basically what I look at is
throughout mankind's history the answers
have always been the gods or a specific
God to like almost every question about
the world around us for example there
was a God of War there was a god of
lightning there was a God of love and
for whatever it is I mean mankind just
really didn't understand the world
around them but as time has progressed
you know through science and technology
we have really been getting a lot of
answers to a lot of the questions around
us and pretty much squashing conspiracy
theories like you don't see people
dancing around a fire sacrificing people
to a volcano anymore worshipping the god
of harvest rain or anything like that
because we have a much better
understanding around the world of us and
and and what I'm feeling is this the
taking accessor a Shinto conspiracy
theories that are out there I honestly
feel that the church is behind a lot of
the stuff out there because it's like
when you have that respectable fear of
something that is greater than any man's
ability to control you it's been able to
allow history to be able to control
people car what church you say the
church what church you're talking about
no just in general religion what I'm
saying is for example if you take back
in the days when people didn't
understand fire okay hey you know you do
as I say otherwise the fire God is going
to get you got it car thanks professor
Barker and what's your reaction well
it's it's important to bear in mind here
that there are non-religious conspiracy
theories in other words there's not
there's no inherent or necessary
connection between conspiracy theories
and religion some are religious some are
some are non religious or even anti
religious as a matter of fact they're
conspiracy theories in which organized
religion is viewed as part of the
conspiracy what I think is worth noting
in regard to your callers comments is
the extent to which conspiracy theories
do attempt to as I said before explain
and make sense of the world and that's
one of their attractions
we're talking with professor michael
barkun he's at Syracuse University do
you do yourself get on the web and try
to find these kind of things or oh yes
the the web has been both an enormous
generator of conspiracy theories and an
extraordinary channel for making them
available to potential mass public so
yes I do a lot of web surfing where
conspiracy theories are concerned
there's a huge amount out there how do
you if they're not if you're not true
and and I mean I don't know whether
these things are true or not but how do
you knock them down if they aren't well
in the first place I I don't necessarily
see myself as a debunker here I don't
mean you I don't mean you necessarily
mean anybody I mean how does this system
knock them down
okay that that can become very difficult
because the more sweeping the claims of
a conspiracy theory are the more it
claims to explain about the world the
harder it is to disprove and there are a
lot of conspiracy theories out there
that are in effect non falsifiable that
is if you present to a believer in them
what you regard as evidence that the
conspiracy theory is false the believer
may well say ah but that evidence was
planted by the conspirators themselves
in order to mislead you and get you on
the wrong track and when that kind of
claim is made you're talking essentially
about a closed system of ideas that is
basically beyond issues of proof and
disprove Clearwater Florida
good morning yes good morning gentlemen
yes my own conspiracy theory is that the
Democratic Party is behind the New World
Order you think about it in order to
have the New World Order you have to
have a weak America you look at the
Democrats are constantly trying to cut
defense cut intelligence trying to bring
us in line with like the European Union
everything about them is that it's like
they basically want us to be on a state
of the European Union
you see Bush is like you know we don't
need their permission and you see all
the Democrats like oh we need the
internationalist let me ask you this
George Herbert Walker Bush was I think
one of the first people ever talk about
the New World Order and he's a
Republican you know he that was all
about the first Gulf War they each I'm
out getting the big coalition no before
that I mean it was part of his whole
presidency but what do you think a new
world order is basically it's one
government that controls the entire
world
so everybody's like basically a state
member of this one baby of the UN oh we
are the whole thing is evil you know
there's there's an evil intention behind
the whole thing what's the evil
intention I don't like the Bible they
talk about it and it's always been what
do they want to do they want to kill
people they want to you know let me
either there's there's gonna be World
Peace and everybody's gonna be a part of
this one big thing one guy is gonna rise
up if you listen you know the you know
the Bible that's gonna be Satan I mean
do you believe that I don't know you not
really I mean I haven't seen it really
the signs but in order to bring this
about you need to basically take
everyone's guns away 600 that's all I
mean it's happening in Australia they've
taken pretty much guns away from
everybody
what do you think professor well one of
the interesting things about the version
of conspiracy theory that your caller
has is the identification of the
conspiracy with a political party
because most contemporary American
conspiracy theories argue the opposite
they they argue that there's no
difference between political parties or
for that matter between ideologies they
would say that it doesn't matter whether
their president is a Republican or a
Democrat it doesn't matter whether one
is identified with the right or the left
those are all superficial because one of
the key characteristics of contemporary
conspiracy theories is the claim that
nothing is as it seems the sort of of
notion that was implicit in an earlier
callers
emphasis on unstaged events so it's
unusual for a conspiracy theory to zero
in on a particular political party
professor has there ever been any
evidence real evidence that there's been
a UFO land here in the United States
with little people on it
from some other land not as far as I am
aware of but I realized that there are
people out there who hold a different
point of view where's it is there of
this particular spot that you guys hear
about area 51 is they they have a hangar
out there where they keep all these
things whether they're there a couple of
areas that that pop up in the conspiracy
literature one of course is area 51
north of of Las Vegas which has been a
restricted military test site for a long
time another much less well known is
supposedly outside of Dulce New Mexico
up near the Colorado border so there you
know there in fact is a kind of a sort
of geography of alleged UFO sites and
then Dulce New Mexico do they have a
community around there that you know
features this kind of thing and well not
not as far as I'm aware I'm not aware
that there's a lot that there's much on
the ground to see but the conspiracy
literature on Dulce argues that there's
an underground laboratory outside of
Dulce that's a cooperative venture of
the US government and the and the
extraterrestrials and that literature
has been out there for a long time but
it's it's one that's less well known
than the area of 51 folklore what kind
of a chance would you give that that's
really a true story personally yes very
much
a scale of one to ten ten being certain
that there is and one being not a chance
would you give it
one yeah IIIi don't see any I don't see
any basis for it but one of the things
that happens and this is again I think a
kind of an artifact of the Internet age
is that stories what folklorist might
refer to as urban legends achieve a
credibility in part by the number of
times that they're repeated the number
of times a story is posted on the on the
Internet gives it a kind of an
appearance of credibility that it would
otherwise not have our guest gets a call
now from Woodruff Wisconsin for a
professor michael barkun you're on the
air hi professor I'm having such a good
time watching this show some of the
early colors have been a real hoot and
you sound sorry you look so bored drinks
some of them I was just wondering what
kind of work you've done maybe or any
sort of conspiracy theory research
you've done not on the traditional UFO
Kennedy conspiracy all the usual
political you know the infamous they
kind of conspiracies but any sort of
research you've done on correlative
conspiracies with like traditional
magical symbols or magic or schools of
magic not necessarily Wicca but more
alchemy alka medical schools and the
connection between the Freemasons and
you know like the the all-seeing eye and
things like that as misses not
necessarily as being more social
political conspiracies by the way Connor
do you believe any of this yourself I do
but it's more because quite be honest it
makes life fun I like conspiracy
theories I'm well I consider myself more
of a 4dn and so you'll follow Allah G
demonology and cryptozoology I just
think it's very interesting thanks
professor well I think it turns out that
a lot of people who believe in political
conspiracies
series are also sympathetic towards
excuse me other examples of what in the
book I call stigmatized knowledge that
is claims about knowledge that have been
rejected by mainstream institutions so
that you will find that there are many
believers in conspiracy theories who as
we've already discussed may have views
about UFOs may believe in it
stories about Atlantis may believe in
alternative or unorthodox medical
theories may believe in cryptozoology
and and and so on so that I think the
line between political conspiracy
theories and non-political what what I
call rejected knowledge claims is not a
sharp one coming up in a few minutes Sam
Weinberg who has a professor in Stanford
will be on this program and he will
discuss history and whether or not
people in this generation are smart on
history as they are back in the early
1920s or the 1800s and we understand our
guests as having trouble hearing at the
moment we'll take a call from Macomb
Louisiana next go ahead please and we'll
pass it on if he can't hear us go ahead
okay yes I have but two sons it belong
to deep eternity when they would LSU and
they had to belong to the fires which is
a club that belongs to the digs and the
same thing at Yale they have this going
bones it goes to do to Eternity so I
don't think there's anything very
serious about that at all paternity said
there will be could be in signal things
like that so that's what I've always you
know I've heard from my children and the
other thing I was kind of wondering if
they used to have something called the
kingmakers back around Eisenhower's era
and I was going to pretend to know about
that too because they picked both the
Republican and Democratic president and
business people you know like great big
companies and don't pick both and I'll
just wanted to be heard anything about
that
alright thanks professor could you hear
that well I had lost the sound for a few
seconds so I did not hear all of the
callers but basically what she was
saying is that she I think she had a son
who belonged to the Deek fraternity and
that they also had to belong to the
friars and she said it was nothing this
column loves nothing but a fraternity
and there's nothing more to it than that
is what's your opinion on that well I
don't know what goes on in in Skull and
Bones the thing about any organization
that has restricted visibility that
makes claims to secrecy is that it's
possible to project onto it anything
that someone on the outside wishes to
whether it's going bones or Bohemian
Grove what are the chances that the
pressure will be so great on Skull and
Bones that they'll have to reveal the
inside information before this election
is over I don't think it's going to
happen by then I think in in time how
long I don't know but in time the
information will probably come out my
guess is a lot of it will turn out to be
pretty frivolous and and innocuous but I
don't think it's going to happen before
the election Galena Illinois you're next
night for wedding thank you Brian for
your good work this is a very populist
I'd like to have the professor talked
about two books by professor Quigley who
taught at Georgetown that Bill Clinton
was a matter of factors first was a I
think called the anglo-american
connection and it's very revealing or
tracing New York people I suppose in the
upper echelons back to English
connections and accomplices were road
starting the roads system the other I
can't is Magisterial SP United States in
which he had missed being kriby
this group he doesn't identifying saying
that they do exist and he actually is
somewhat sympathetic to their views now
you know well I can't remember the name
of that but maybe if you'd mention that
and the anglo-american connection people
could really read up something
professional on this and remember Freud
said there are no accidents
thanks well there there is what might be
termed a at least a semi scholarly
conspiracy literature in other words a
conspiracy literature that does pay some
attention to the normal canons of of a
proof the other hand the response to it
whether in the form of responses to
carroll quigley or others who write in
that genre has still been a good deal of
skepticism because freud to the contrary
notwithstanding i think many of us who
study human behavior do believe that
that there are accidents and other than
in some ultimate metaphysical sense all
things are not necessarily
interconnected Fort Collins Colorado
you're on with professor michael barkun
good morning good morning I had heard
that Winston Churchill knew about Pearl
Harbor before that happened and I was
just wondering if you thought that was a
conspiracy that he let it happen knowing
that it would pull the u.s. into the war
thanks well there there was and I
suppose to some extent remains Pearl
Harbor conspiracy theory literature
these are what I refer to in the book as
event conspiracies conspiracy theories
that are intended
to explain events that otherwise appear
inexplicable or can't simply be assigned
to human folly or accident because it's
psychologically too disturbing for that
the the problem with Pearl Harbor of
course was to explain how this could
happen
without some kind of advanced knowledge
on the part of of some allied
governments it's it's very much of a
piece with some of the conspiracy
theories that have arisen in the wake of
September 11th in other words how could
this happen without somebody knowing in
in advance we don't want to believe that
that kind of event is possible it's much
more comforting for us psychologically
to believe that someone in authority
knew but let it happen that is that
there was someone in control Hamilton
Montana
good morning go ahead please I just do
things I'd like to bring up so you think
over it seems to me mr. Parkinson it's
your job to know about you know as much
as you can possibly possibly know about
skull and bones and other you know
secret societies if you set yourself up
as an expert I would think that you
would you know Alex Jones is an expert
because he'll in this every moment of
his life is is exposing these piano
people and do you believe him by the way
Hamilton well I it just resonates it
rings true but please let me just make
this other point just because it's a
conspiracy theory doesn't mean that it
isn't valid
look at what 40 years has what how much
information 40 years had brought out
about the JFK assassination that was
considered a balderdash you know in the
beginning it's human nature to look at
things especially if you are extremely
intellectual like mr. Barkin Brian for
example if you could bring somebody on
that isn't so left brained you know who
is almost just close-minded completely
because of their intellect their
intellect is so strong that they cannot
see that there's truth to this there
might it not might not be completely
true not every detail but let me give
you an example this morning i was
listening to alex jones on this show
coast to coast am he's talking about the
way he's talking about Bohemian Grove
and the importance of all these people
meeting and then he makes a statement
that President Bush when he wasn't
president sealed the deal with Dick
Cheney there at the Bohemian Grove to be
his vice presidential candidate and when
I was listening I said to myself Vice
President Cheney was the head of his
committee to find a vice president why
do they need to go to the Bohemian Grove
to settle this deal and look at all of
the things we have found out about Danny
as being at being a CEO of Halliburton
and things like that
we knew that before the election that
that's dishonest it's it's not what's
decide upfront Haney is a very secretive
man but you mentioned Halla bribe you
you mentioned Halliburton what's secret
about that we knew he had had at
Halliburton a conflict of interest
nobody will say the word it is a
conflict of interest for him to be in
the oil business and be a millionaire
alright thanks professor Barkin there
you have it well I'm not sure I'm not
sure what - what what what what to
respond to about the left brain that
comment well I don't know since I'm left
hand that I suppose that makes me right
brain she thought you should know more
about things like skullenbones well i
let's put it this way i I can know what
I think is knowable but if one traces
back the claims that are made by those
who say that they're exposing
organizations whether they're
skullenbones of the trilateral
commission or what-have-you
it turns out that the that the the basis
of evidence on which they are relying is
is extremely questionable even though
they speak of course very often with
with great certainty the fact that a
particular story rings true or resonates
and in in in the language of some of
your callers may mean that it's a
compelling account but that does not
mean necessarily that it's a it's a true
account one of the great attractions of
conspiracy theories to believers is the
sense of possessing special knowledge
possessing a truth not available to
others and by contrast devaluing the
conception of reality that might come
through either from universities or
mainstream media or some other source
we're out of time we need Dallas Texas
for our last call go ahead please you're
on the air hello hi hi hello I was in
the military intelligence stationed at a
Space Command and you know I worked in a
sensitive compartmented information area
you know all the other manuals are
partner eyes within themselves so it
it's very difficult for normal people
even to understand you know what they
were given that information to rebut you
know if you're very intelligent then you
know you can make connections of the
information information which is you
know called like remote Association so
some people that have worked in you know
top secret areas do you know what you
know truly going on but well but the
quick question I are you saying that
there are unidentified flying objects
and you know them from reading these
reports I'm just saying I'm just saying
that things information like that would
even be it's like an enigma within an
inning but you had to the the remote
associations are so so far apart thanks
Carla out of time professor Bergen last
comment
so last comment I suppose would be that
in in a world where a lot of things are
going on that we don't quite understand